in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on Deutsche Welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape with me the
studio with perfect hair is dr. Natalie
Garcia butters
she's a dermatologist and assistant
director of the clinical research center
for hair and skin sciences at the
Charity Hospital here in Berlin hello
and welcome to the show
hello thanks speaking about this
autohemotherapy what do you think about
this is it a sensible approach well it
is not a con it is not considered as a
guideline therapy because there are no
scientific studies and research
approvals that show that this is a
serious therapy it may help in
individuals but it is not considered a
standard therapy so it's nothing you use
at the Charity Hospital is a standard
therapy then definitely not and talking
about hair loss how much is normal when
I look at my brush in the morning a
plenty of hair well we consider normal
everything below hundred hairs per day
and if you lose more than hundred days
every day and this over a longer period
of time this is a symptom we consider as
serious hair loss and it has a several
causes and there's something like
genetically hair loss and this normally
hits men and not so many women why is
that well there are a lot of genetic
projects actually going on to answer
these questions we don't have the
question yet at the answer yet but
however also women are a consider to
have genetic hair loss and if you go for
a therapy do you have to start the
therapy early or can you take your time
well definitely you should start the
therapy early but however you shouldn't
diagnose yourself and therapy use the
therapy you choose yourself you should
consult a dermatologist to clearly get a
diagnosis and to individually
your disease in the main drugs in
treating those is minoxidil and
finasteride those are drugs and they
were developed for something like
prostate hyperplasia so do they have
side effects
well these drug therapies are mainly
developed for genetically induced hair
loss and of course they do have some
side effects but however every doctor
will talk with you about the individual
risk for side effects and then you
decide whether you take it or not and
how high are the success rates and
treating arrows well usually
minoxidil and finasteride have a success
rate to stop hair loss about 70 to 80
percent however in a part of these
successfully stopped hair loss patients
they profit from regrowing hair but this
is not all of the 70% of profit from
regrowth of hair University doctor of
the charity and we got a question from a
viewer mr. an email and he wants to know
is there something in the pipeline in
the future for new developments in
treating hair loss well around the world
a lot of researchers try to develop new
therapies against hair loss and one
approach is the stem cell therapy
however we don't have a therapy now
which can we which we can use in
patients and a second new molecule could
be Latin or prost which is now in the
first step to be investigated if it
really helps against hair loss but so
far you can't use it against something
in pipeline and we just have to wait
never wear a hairpiece again this is
great so is this a typical case well
this is not the typical case that
hormones are the most frequent cause in
women - cause hair loss however it
always has to be considered in women -
as a as a cause especially when they
have the genetically appearance of hair
loss and but there are many causes for
hair loss
- cause diffuse hair loss and their
different forms going further than the
use hair loss there's something like
spot baldness or patchy baldness and
this is a thing where patients who have
typically present with round and
completely bald areas at the scalp you
just see it here in the pictures
scientists now believe that spot
baldness is caused by immune system
reaction when protective mechanism begin
to win interview body's own hair
follicles as invaders so what do you
know about the ball about the sport
baldness and how do you treat it well
what we know so far that there are also
genetically causes and there is a lot of
research going on to really uncover the
genes who are responsible for patchy
hair loss however we also know that the
immune system can be treated in a way
that we suppress the immune system in
this disease were that we start to guide
the immune system in a different way and
there are different therapies topically
or systemically to be used in this
patchy hair loss when we usually talk
about immune things and I always think
about stress induced immune deficits and
do you think that stress can play a role
in patchy hair loss well there always
have been a lot of reports however a
scientifically proved it has not been
published yet that stress really induces
patchy hair loss but we have a lot of
patients who report this so it is really
likely that there's an association okay
and let's talk about some special
shampoos or haircare products you can
just get over-the-counter or in the
pharmacy and are they really helpful in
preventing or in treating hair loss when
we talk about a scientifically proven
effect I just have to answer no because
when we consider a therapy as effective
we need evidence-based therapies and
there are usually scientifically proven
and these over-the-counter therapies you
are talking about are usually not
scientifically proven so if they don't
help and if the pharmacy doesn't help me
when do I need to see a doctor
well definitely in the case of hair loss
you should you should consult a
dermatologist as early as you can
because the earlier you treat hair loss
the better your result will be thank you
so much for being with us in the studio
thank you thank you
you